here's what would happen if we threw one
and a half billion phone cases into the
Mariana Trench these are all the old
phone cases that are thrown out every
year so to get rid of them why not throw
them down to the deepest point in the
ocean if you were to pile these all into
a massive ball and drop it in it would
quickly fall to the bottom and this many
phone cases wouldn't really put a dent
into this massive ocean Cavern the phone
cases would just get compressed and
become smaller and smaller but that's
not all throwing this many phone cases
into the ocean would cause major
pollution for the sea the materials from
the phone cases would leak killing ocean
wildlife and it would affect us as well
we'd notice it in the fishweed the water
we drink and the places we swim a better
way to get rid of our phone cases give
them to case defy they have the world's
largest phone case recycling program you
give them your old one and they produce
a brand new phone case so